call me by your name stars army hammer
and Timothy sha'lame as Oliver and Elio
two young men in northern Italy in 1983
who meet because Oliver has come to help
Elias father as a research assistant and
the two of them spent a summer becoming
closer and closer as they both learn
things about themselves they never knew
this film has been around the festival
circuit it's being nominated for tons of
awards it's been buzzed about and lauded
for months and I have been dying to see
it and having seen it I can see why this
is a beautiful film one that is
startlingly real it feels so
blisteringly sensual and in the moment
that it's almost impossible to ignore as
you watch the film it doesn't unfold
like most films it's in no way
traditional in its storytelling usually
when you're writing a screenplay there's
rules that writers go by like the
inciting incident must happen on page 15
to 20 or things like that at some point
you must realize where the hero's
motivation lies or where the villains
motivation lies this film sidesteps
basically all of cinema's rules and is
very lazy and purposely meandering
because it's about two guys who are
meandering through a summer discovering
things about themselves and as these
characters explore this blossoming
relationship the film just becomes
something really beautiful and it really
does have something to do with the fact
that when I look back on this movie I
feel like I was there I feel like I was
in Italy it captures its location and
the feel of the surroundings so well
that it doesn't feel like you're
watching a movie really it almost feels
like you're a fly on the wall watching
documented events speaking of flies
there's a lot of them in this film and
some might think well that was just a
coincidence and I thought it was just a
coincidence until the final shot which I
won't get into but there's a fly
involved in this final shot and thinking
back on the movie there's a lot of flies
involved in the film and you start to
wonder
with a film that's this well directed
was this something intentional as
they're deeper meaning to all these
flies or is it just because they live
around a lot of fruit and it's a hot
summer day and is it pointless to wonder
if these flies have any meaning to the
actual story well if you actually want
to get into that which I kind of do
because I like to look at films that way
what really is a fly's life it's short
it's here and gone and then it's just
it's disappeared and in some ways this
summer for these characters is like that
it's this short fleeting thing that's
that's very impactful to both of them
but it's over like that and I don't know
if that has anything to do with the
flies it could also be that there's this
pesky thing that both of them can't
really ignore that's always going to be
there for them it's one of those things
where I feel like it's kind of silly to
just sit here and talk about flies that
are constantly in this film and I
thought it was a coincidence until the
final shot it's just so glaringly right
there that there's must be some meat in
fact at at a press conference the
director himself refused to talk about
this he didn't want to give any meaning
or any hints of any kind and it kind of
felt like denis villeneuve x' spiders an
enemy because there's a meaning to them
and they're definitely there but he he
won't he won't talk about it and I could
go on and on about different things in
this film that are thrown into each
scene that could have more of a meaning
than it really does and in some ways
that could just be really pretentious
and maybe that's not even what the
director was going for but what is most
certain about this film are the two lead
performances by Armie Hammer and Timothy
sha'lame they're fantastic both of these
actors have insanely good chemistry it's
palpable
it's sultry there's something
devastatingly romantic about what they
accomplished on the screen and the two
of them together work real magic this is
a film that sometimes could be very
boring because it does show things that
you don't necessarily need to know
sometimes you see elio just writing
notes about his music because he has an
interest in music sometimes the two of
them are just sitting around looking at
scenery
maybe there's a really long shot of them
just
swimming in a pond for no particular
reason other than look at this beautiful
moment with these two characters and
it's these moments that make you feel
like you're there and it creates that
sense of realism that most films just
don't have even in the sound design they
don't try to make it seem like a movie
it feels very realistic in an early
scene the two characters are sitting at
a table outside by the street and cars
are passing behind them and they have to
raise their voice to talk over the cars
the sound of the cars isn't drowned out
of the mix it's right there just like it
would be if you were sitting there and
it just lends to that feel of realism
and environment it's also a film that's
emotion builds and builds and kind of
sneaks up on you because it is
purposefully slow-paced it's a slow burn
without a doubt but towards the third
act of the film as the summer is winding
down the impact of the events for these
characters is really felt a lot more
significantly and you don't get some of
those arcs that most screenplays will
give you just like the fact that the
inciting incident is not on page 15 or
15 minutes into the movie you don't get
those pretty clean character arcs that
make you go home casts that's great life
is filled with hope sometimes things are
complicated and very complex especially
with these two men having feelings for
each other and so the film doesn't have
any easy answers and it doesn't give the
characters an easy way out as for flaws
I would have liked to have known a
little more about the characters
especially Oliver they're they're very
much so kept at arm's length you
basically learn what you see and a few
things that you hear you don't know that
much about either of the characters just
really the things that the film needs
you to know it would have been nice if I
was a little more attached to them I
felt for them but I just didn't really
know that much about them and yes the
pace being so deliberately slow can
sometimes wear on your patience a little
bit but this film is just so different
and so unique that that didn't really
bother me too much
I suppose my biggest issue is that I
wish there were more obstacles set in
the way of these characters there just
wasn't that many hardships in their way
beyond time and their situation
sometimes ripping them apart from each
other it would have been nice if there
was a little more obstacles a film that
dealt with similar themes last year was
the best picture winter moonlight which
was also about a young man discovering
things about himself that he was unsure
of and conflicted about but in his
environment that he lived in he was
confronted with so many things that made
that lifestyle extremely difficult in
this film the characters don't have as
many things to worry about which i think
would have perhaps gave more drama to
the story all that being said call me by
your name is a very romantic extremely
well directed and very well acted film
and if you get a chance to see it I
recommend it I'm gonna give calmly by
your name and a - guys thank you so much
as always for watching look forward to
more videos coming very soon and as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck man eyes
[Music]